the new right now new push in California
is for a product called flash frozen its
cannabis that is loaded into a trailer
it's literally cryofreeze down to 20
below and what happens is they take this
then and bring it to a large press we
actually put it in our back of our
trucks the trucks have the ability to
are refrigerated so it's hold a
temperature at about 19 degrees so we
transport this as an example we did
2,200 pounds brought it to a facility
they put it under a press and they
squeeze it the unusual thing about this
is the plant doesn't realize that it's
dead unlike other programs we or herb
and I know this is not gonna make some
of the other guys happy but as far as
the way that you process it if you
process it with co2 if you process it
with ethanol if you process with some
sort of nitrogen gas there seems to be a
residual taste that's left over yeah and
so some people tell me that listen I
don't like it because of that reason
with the flash froze frozen you're
literally just squeezing the SAP right
out of the plant so you're dealing with
a pure process which is completely
different than anything else that you're
gonna experience and I think that's
truly gonna be the future of it it's a
cleaner burn you're not using butane
from Oh from a lighter you don't have to
worry about paper if that saw the way
you'd ingest your cannabis it actually
comes in at oil there's no there's no
smell it's very discreet do you vape it
it's actually a vape okay it's actually
a vape um the problem is that it's very
expensive to set this process in place
obviously cryo freezing and getting it
down to right it's not cheap yeah 40
below is but listen you're getting a top
quality product at the end of the day so